Những ngày đồng tháng 1 năm mang những không tra bị sống giả cảnh,
quá tư dùng tại video dưới là gây nhận dù hướng tăng mạnh.
Chào bất cảnh tình hình chính trị và anh nên giến miếng phức tạp,
sau chính xe quân sự của Mỹ và viên bắt sữa tổng thống đi của LAS Maduro.
Tại thủ đô Khá Rho Thas, nhiều cuối vực trở nên trong lắng như người dân vẫn se phản tích chứng thực phẩm.
Chỉ quên lắm thời kêu gọi duy trị xin hoạm mình thường,
sau tâm lý lòng ngày viên quý cơ khăn hiếm đã thúc đầy lần sống tích chứng,
trong khi giá các bạn thản thiết dụ tăng ngành,
một số khu trở về cửa hàng phải tạp đúng gửa, giờ lòng ngày mất anh nền,
trong khi lực lượng chức năng tăng cường cân chá để giữ chất tự.
Vì như giữa là một nữ quên với tình trạng làm phát cao,
và ngôn công thiếu ordent trong nhiều năng qua,
hỗ trời điểm là phát tự đạp mức đặc biệt nghiêm trọng,
bao năm nay ngày không trìm mày tảm,
kể tôi đó không cộng bố thêm,
khi anh này lĩnh phòng tả năng lượng của Mỹ được sự báo sẽ làm xúc sảm mạnh,
ngôn thông ngân xách,
ra tăng áp lực linh xa cá và đùi sống người dân bên dưới xây la trong thời gian tới.